deuxième vidéo de notre série sur la
santé sexuelle la dernière fois vous
vous souvenez on avait discrédité
quelques crottes de taureau sur la
sexualité aujourd'hui on va parler d'un
orgasme
en fait bah bougez pas on va en parler
tout de suite justement c'est quand même
bien fait allez hop
[Musique]
donc nouvelle vidéo sur la santé
sexuelle j'en profite pour vous dire que
j'ai bien reçu vos questions par mail
n'hésitez surtout pas à continuer à m'en
envoyer il y en a certaines dont la
réponse va être un petit peu trop courte
pour que je le fasse ici sur youtube
mais du coup je vais le faire aussi sur
TikTok insta etc donc n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner à mes réseaux sociaux parce
que c'est aussi par la bague ça va se
passer les liens sont dans la
description et bien sûr tout est anonyme
alors l'orgasme on en avait déjà parlé
ici dans une vidéo que je vous invite à
aller voir ou à retourner voir mais
aujourd'hui on va parler d'absence
d'orgasmes ou de troubles de l'orgasme
mais avant de commencer je voulais vous
parler d'un truc il y a pas longtemps
c'était Pâques et regardez un peu ce que
les cloches ont déposé dans mon petit
panier
bon en vrai je dis les cloches je suis
pas très sympa parce qu'en fait c'est
Amorelli qui a déposé ça dans mon petit
panier et en plus il sponsorise cette
vidéo Amorelli c'est une boutique en
ligne qui vend de la lingerie des
sex-toys et tout un tas de produits
adaptés à tous les types de sexualité et
de pratique c'est aussi une marque qui
crée ses propres toys comme cette œuvre
vibrant par exemple cette vibrant avec
télécommande comme ça vous pouvez vous
en servir au solo ou à plusieurs et vous
pouvez vous en servir n'importe où chez
vous en vacances au restaurant vous
pouvez même faire une chasse aux œufs
alors tu es froid et là glacial et là
[Musique]
là
qui prône une sexualité positive et qui
porte des valeurs comme la libération de
la parole le body positive l'inclusivité
et l'acceptation de soi autant vous dire
qu'on est sur la même longueur d'onde
parce que c'est précisément le but de
cette série de vidéos sur la santé
sexuelle donc si vous avez envie de vous
laisser tenter par ce petit œuf il
s'appelle will
ça veut dire tourbillon en anglais ou
par une box ou parce que vous voulez en
fait parce que vous faites bien ce que
vous voulez je vous offre 20% de
réduction sur tout le site Amorelli sauf
sur ce qui est déjà en promo abusez pas
niveau rapport qualité prix c'est déjà
top donc 20 % de réduction donc avec le
code DTC 20 c'est valable jusqu'au 4 mai
donc très n'est pas je vous ai tout mis
dans la description bon mais l'orgasme
alors dans la dernière vidéo je vous ai
dit ça si chaque partenaire a un orgasme
c'est déjà bien ou en tout cas si chaque
personne qui peut en avoir un on a un
parce que tout le monde peut pas en
avoir mais ça on en reparlera un de ces
jours vous êtes titiés un peu cette
phrase là et bah un de ces jours c'est
aujourd'hui donc voilà on y va tout de
suite première question est-ce que c'est
vrai qu'il y a des gens qui ne peuvent
pas avoir d'orgasme bon j'avoue c'est
pas vrai j'ai tout inventé pour faire
mon intérêt mais si bien sûr que c'est
vrai j'irai jamais inventé un truc
pareil en plus la santé c'est du sérieux
donc le fait de ne pas pouvoir avoir
d'orgasme ça s'appelle la norgation et
vous allez voir qu'il y a aussi tout un
tas de cas de figure qui s'approchent
plus ou moins de la norgasmie sans être
la même chose exactement
comme j'ai dit la définition de la
narnation c'est le fait de ne pas
atteindre l'orgasme mais si vous
farfouillez un peu dans les différentes
définitions je veux dire bah vous allez
voir que c'est pas si simple parfois
c'est décrit comme une incapacité
réitérer et persistante à atteindre
l'orgasme alors que dans le Dictionnaire
de l'Académie de médecine on parle
d'absence ou de retard après une période
d'excitation normale de l'orgasme
absence retard bon déjà c'est pas clair
si c'est un retard d'orgasme est-ce que
ça serait pas plutôt ce qu'on appelle
une dissorgasmie d'ailleurs un trouble
de l'orgasme ce que je vous propose
c'est de se dire qu'on s'en fout en fait
de se concentrer sur le concret et de
considérer qu'il y a plusieurs stades et
plusieurs formes d'un orgasme
et puisque je vous propose aussi avant
de continuer c'est de voir non parce que
c'est la norgasmi mais ce que ça n'est
pas la norgasmine ça n'est pas un
trouble de la libido l'envie elle est là
elle est présente il y a du désir c'est
juste l'orgasme qui est absent la
norgasme ça n'est pas la sexualité donc
plus la sexualité c'est l'absence
d'attirance sexuelle on en reparlera
dans une autre vidéo là d'orgasmie ça
n'est pas la frigidité ça c'est un terme
un peu nul on va se l'avouer pour
décrire l'absence ou la diminution de
plaisir pendant les rapports sexuels
alors que quand on a une anorgasmie ça
nous empêche pas de ressentir du plaisir
la norgasmine ça n'est pas une
cassolette d'escargot bah non ça n'a
rien à voir enfin qu'est-ce que vous
raconter voilà donc la norgasmi c'est
rien de tout ça mais attention ça peut
être la cause ou la conséquence de ce
dont on vient de parler on peut avoir
une anorgasmi et des troubles de la
libido par exemple c'est possible mais
c'est juste deux choses différentes bon
on commence à aller voir un petit peu
plus clair mais en fait comment ça
marche on commence à en fait je sais pas
rapport sexuel quand on a une annorga
semi ça se passe comme n'importe quel
rapport sexuel à un détail près il y a
une attirance il y a une envie du désir
il y a une excitation qui monte avec son
cocktail de substance chimique produite
par l'organisme et puis le rapport
sexuel arrive selon les goûts les
habitudes les envies de chacun et de
chacune sauf que l'un des deux
partenaires n'atteint pas l'orgasme ou
les deux d'ailleurs ou les 12 si c'est
une soirée à table alors première chose
on en a parlé juste avant il faut pas
confondre orgasme et plaisir mais il
faut pas confondre non plus orgasme et
éjaculation il peut y avoir éjaculation
sans orgasme déjà quand on stimule un
pénis de façon répétée mécaniquement on
peut arriver à produire une éjaculation
sans qu'il y ait forcément la dimension
de plaisir très forte qu'on appelle
l'orgasme ça s'appelle une éjaculation
anhédonique à l'inverse c'est possible
d'avoir un orgasme donc cette fameuse
sensation de plaisir par oxystique sans
éjaculation c'est ce qu'on appelle une
Anne éjaculation orgasmique ou orgasme
sec ça peut arriver dans plusieurs cas
de figure mais c'est pas le sujet
deuxième chose là j'ai parlé
d'éjaculation mais la norgasmi ça peut
toucher tout le monde et ça n'a rien à
voir avec le vaginisme donc on parlera
aussi une autre fois troisième chose je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez mais j'ai
dit qu'on pouvait considérer qu'il y
avait plusieurs stades et plusieurs
formes d'un orgation si vous souvenez
pas de ça je veux pas vous alarmer mais
peut-être consulté parce que c'était
littéralement il y a une minute donc
plusieurs stades plusieurs formes déjà
elle peut être primaire secondaire
situationnelle on va pas rentrer dans
les détails techniques c'est pas très
intéressant et puis selon les
définitions elle peut être totale et
permanente c'est à dire jamais d'orgasme
dans aucune situation elle peut être
intermittente c'est à dire un coup ça
vient un coup ça vient pas ou alors
parfois c'est juste très long à venir et
parfois l'orgasme vient pas du tout où
on se décourage avant parce que c'est
vraiment très long à venir et puis il y
a aussi des personnes qui ont une
anorgasmie quand elles ont un rapport
sexuel avec une ou un partenaire mais
qui n'en ont pas quand est-ce masturbe
voilà donc ça peut se manifester de
différentes façons ok mais est-ce que
c'est irréversible alors ça par contre
c'est assez clair ça dépend de la cause
évidemment si le problème est
neurologique c'est à dire si les nerfs
sont touchés soit par une maladie comme
le diabète ou la sclérose en plaques par
exemple ou s'ils ont été abîmés par un
accident ou par une opération là ça peut
être compliqué mais tout ça ça reste
rare parce que dans 95% des cas la cause
elle est psychologique et là on peut
faire quelque chose ça veut pas dire
qu'on va réussir forcément à régler le
problème à tous les coups mais c'est
possible en tout cas mais alors du coup
comment ça soigne bah comme on vient de
le dire faut prendre le problème à la
racine donc ça dépend de la cause si
c'est une maladie au niveau des nerfs au
niveau des hormones etc il faut la
soigner c'est globalement des maladies
dont on guérit pas mais on peut les
équilibrer ou les limiter et ça peut
régler le problème d'un orgasme si c'est
causé par un médicament parce que oui il
y a des médicaments qui provoquent ça
comme certains antidépresseurs par
exemple ou si c'est lié à l'alcool ou à
la drogue parce que c'est aussi des
causes bah faut essayer soit de changer
de traitement soit de se sevrer dans
tous les cas si on a une Ann orgasmique
il faut aller consulter un médecin pour
éliminer ou pour identifier une de ses
causes là mais on l'a vu dans l'immense
majorité des cas la cause elle est
psychologique ça peut être en rapport
avec l'éducation qu'on a reçu avec son
vécu avec ses expériences sexuelles ça
peut être un traumatisme en lien avec la
sexualité ça peut être la peur d'avoir
un enfant ça peut être le signe d'un
problème avec son ou avec ça partenaire
ça peut être une pression qu'on se met à
soi-même par rapport à l'orgasme à
l'obligation d'avoir un orgasme à la
performance sexuelle ça peut être une
incapacité à lâcher prise ça peut être
mille trucs différents en fait donc il y
a mille façons de soigner ça mais je
vais quand même vous donner quatre trucs
qui a bien d'abord il faut accepter le
problème pour deux raisons la première
c'est que il faut pas gâcher son énergie
à s'énerver contre quelque chose qui est
là de toute façon ça marche pas et son
énergie on va en avoir besoin pour
régler le problème justement
le deuxième c'est d'éviter le cercle
vicieux plus on se met la pression plus
on se stresse avec l'absence d'orgasme
plus on sécrète des hormones du stress
et celle là c'est les pires ennemis de
l'orgasme c'est un peu comme lutter
contre une insomnie si vous voulez plus
on se prend la tête avec la peur de pas
dormir moi on arrive à dormir ensuite
parler en avec une ou avec un
professionnel je parle de psy par
exemple de sexologue
parlez-en avec un pro pour identifier la
cause et la traiter et puis aussi parce
qu'il peut vous donner des exercices
concrets pour vous aider à retrouver le
chemin de l'orgasme donc parlez-en à des
pros mais pas seulement troisième
conseil par les ans avec votre ou avec
vos partenaires est-ce que c'est encore
un secret pour qui que ce soit que la
communication c'est la base de la
sexualité
non non expliquez la situation discutais
en ensemble et puis profitez-en pour
rassurer votre partenaire s'il y a
besoin parce qu'il peut se poser plein
de questions c'est pas un problème de
désir c'est pas un problème d'attirance
c'est pas un problème d'excitation c'est
pas que c'est pas bien
personne peut se poser plein de
questions donc rassurez là et écoutez ce
qu'elle vous répond en retour bref
parlez-en le plus ouvertement possible
et puis dernier truc profitez de ce que
vous avez quand même ok pas avoir
d'orgasme ça peut être frustrant il
s'agit pas de lier le problème mais un
rapport sexuel ça se limite pas à
l'orgasme donc en attendant de régler ça
si c'est possible concentrez-vous sur ce
qui marche bien le plaisir que vous
ressentez le plaisir que vous donnez etc
plus vous dédramatisez plus vous
désacralisez l'orgasme plus il a de
chances de revenir voilà DTC c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très
vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des
autres mettez-vous bien et surtout
portez-vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]